[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host
dr john deloney is my co-host today
ramsey personality best-selling author
of the book
redefining anxiety and we're inviting
your calls here toll-free and nationwide
at triple eight
eight two five five two two five as we
talk about your life
and talk about your money triple eight
eight two five
five two two five
so um john posted on instagram
i dared to do this that uh
that people should be nice to each other
and you did that on the day of the
inauguration people should be nice to
each other
and apparently it's not okay to say you
should be nice to each other
so just for everyone listening i it's
the most hate mail he's ever gotten
so i've really been messing with him
this is awesome so just all the
conservatives said you're a liberal and
all the liberals said well where have
you been
to protect our rights all along that's
right so
you you just screwed up you screwed
everybody i used asking them to be nice
the u word
oh i know don't usually you word and so
i don't watch the news just as a general
principle because i care about my mental
and social and physical and spiritual
health so i stay away from that
and i communicate with questions you're
naive as chris
evidently does so i'm walking through
the office
and i see the end of the inauguration i
stick my head in and say oh yeah that
was today
like a terrible citizen i get that and
then i see karl rove come out and say
i'm just going to say it that was a good
speech and i thought
well america's over right and then i
thought yeah karl rove says it's a good
speech
biden has a good speech the second
coming of jesus is about on us
either it's freezing over or yeah hey
we're all coming together it's gonna
we're gonna come together and dave you
know me i always think
everyone's gonna come together at the
end whoo boy so i have i'm leaving the
office after my show yesterday and i
posted
hey it's time for everybody to come
together we're gonna be unified we're
going to say i'm sorry we're going to
ask one more question like
i don't know what you mean by that can
you help me don't you
you were asking people will be nice and
that's just that's illegal
just be kind i'm surprised that facebook
hasn't completely thrown you off because
that's kind of asking people to be nice
is hate speech john i have an unread
message from zuckerberg he emailed me
last night
i'll open it when i get the courage
could we just stop
we just stop people would rather
have a terrible day than say
hey man tell me what you mean by that
people would rather have a bad marriage
the hilarious thing is is that you're so
politically naive
that you have no idea that you just
walked down the alley asking to get hit
by both sides oh i told somebody cause
it's like a gauntlet you walk people are
emailing i said you're
so funny i just walked through my
girlfriend's front yard and stepped in
dog poo and tracked it all over her
parents house without even realizing
that's what i did i had no idea
[Laughter]
hey get this dave the first person who
wrote me said something along the lines
of
oh i see what's going on in china and
conspiracy and i wrote
back and i no you didn't you answered it
hey i thought it was good
you've got to stop dave i wrote i wrote
ha ha ha awesome i thought they were
messing with me
here's the thing they were super nice
they're really mentally ill
they were not messing with me the
unabomber just sent you a message on
instagram
man listen listen hey the good news is
is that mental illness is everywhere and
so you got a big job dude i tell you
what you got almost as big a job as i do
getting people out of debt and jenny
craig does
the three of us are gonna be employed
are eternally employable
forever and if i'll just shut my mouth
the chicks will just deposit themselves
be nice be nice let's be
let's be willing to listen to other
people's ideas
oh god you're a liberal
i do i didn't know i didn't i had to go
on instagram to find out john was a
liberal i had no idea
oh man oh man
i did can you imagine dave i think i
just think we need to stir in a little
anthony o'neal see if we can make it
even
more messed up no when anthony when
anthony texts you and goes he just wrote
bro that's it that's what i knew
i'm probably in trouble i don't know
what i did
oh jeez louise well
if you all don't know john has been a
ramsey personality for a little
under a year now and so he's gotten um a
few baptisms by fire and
learning that the trolls and the uh
singular words misused in the wrong
timing on social media will get you hate
mail
by the bushel well here's the thing dave
i
will bail mine man i will oh yeah we
don't answer i answer all letters that
come today ramsey
they go to patty's desk we answer every
one of them except hate mail yeah and um
send them to me i'm gonna respond to
them no no no i use them for kindling
there you go
i have to have something to light my
fires in the winter and there's a lot of
kindling at my house
so man yeah it's it's i'm not gonna stop
talking about this one thing okay
if somebody has hurt you in the past if
somebody
um disagrees with you
all going to ward accomplishes i'll find
if you
if finding somebody new to hate dave
will not solve any of your problems
and if you want to have a conversation
great it doesn't mean kindness doesn't
mean you're going to agree
kindness doesn't mean we're not going to
fight hard kind means i'm going to be
respectful i'm going to listen to you
so i'm going to keep encouraging people
in your homes with your kids in your
workplace
in your community wherever
just listen first just listen and if you
don't understand ask this next question
i don't understand what you mean by that
keep keep coming on that
fill me in and man you all we often will
find
we are way way closer together on so
many things man
so many things you see you're making the
assumption there that you're dealing
with someone who's not mad
i know i know i just have such a high
view of people
you're so kind and sweet hey those
christie wright texted me last night she
says if you're stupid and off
track me listening to you ain't going to
keep you from being stupid you're right
check it back check back with him in one
more year oh man
man after you've had a few more emails
from the unabomber and then we'll see
we're going to blow up the building
please don't
i don't i want to tell my kids bye
yeah well uh usually people that are
gonna blow up the building
don't tell you they're going to so
that's the good news okay
who knows man are you listening
do not use the word unity don't don't
say we want to be unified
don't say kindness don't say nice just
say
don't say sorry don't say say you're
sorry don't ever never be sorry
never be sorry i can't hey you know what
those people are gonna cut and paste
this and they're gonna say see
and it's gonna be me and dave going
don't say sorry don't say sorry
you know what it ain't the first time
it's happened okay
louise there's so much video of me on
youtube that has been cut and pasted is
it awesome
it's just um yeah i've said a lot of
stuff i never said
hey james did that to me the other day
and it's fantastic man
yeah the guys in our booth they can put
together stuff on us and they do it
frequently just to mess with us well the
problem with james is what i said i
actually said so i can't really have it
context context is overrated
yeah oh well there we go oh
be kind america be kind be unified
slow
we got some crap we got to figure out
geez oh this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices and they make it
simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five ryan is in columbus
ohio hi ryan welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi david john thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
um so my wife and i just paid off our
house last october so we're in baby step
seven and we're trying to figure out
yeah
we're trying to figure out what to do
with the extra money we're having from
not having a mortgage payment
way to go such problems
yeah so my wife's the dentist and she's
currently buying into the practice that
she works at
we're actually able to do this without
taking out a loan by her paying her a
partner each month
for equity in the practice and then
their plan was to do this for four years
and then at the end of the fourth year
she would purchase the rest of the
practice from him
so we're currently in the last year of
that plan and we're planning on getting
a business loan to pay off the rest of
the practice you know after this year
so my question is with that um
with that business loan coming up in the
next year
and we have all this extra money from
not having a house payment anymore
should we save up that money and take
out a smaller loan
yep or should we need more no longer to
save for retirement or no loan
yeah can you how much is the loan how
much is the
buyout at the end of the end of the year
it's about four hundred and eighty
thousand dollars that you're going to
need
more than if she's already paid in
yes whoo
so it's a serious practice or you're
seriously overpaying
um um okay anyway i
i want you to go relook those numbers
and just make sure that you're not
overpaying for this
uh dentists yeah have a reputation for
overpaying
yeah we have a uh we have a accountant
that works in uh buying out dental
practices
he looked at the numbers and he said for
our area for the size of the practice
this was a good price he actually said
we're getting a deal
so okay all right it must be mammoth
okay
um okay so what's your household income
um combined right now with her paying
her partner
is about two hundred thousand dollars
okay but then after
after she owns the entire practice she
says we'll probably be
uh 350 thousand dollars conservatively
okay so uh yeah what i would like you to
do is to save as much as you can
possibly save
almost like you're on baby step two
again
uh real intensity because i really don't
want you to have this loan but it sounds
like you're going to
but let's make it as small as you can
possibly make it and then let's pay it
off as fast as you possibly can
um okay we've done a lot of work over
the years with a lot of dentists
in entre leadership and also just in
financial coaching
and um the uh
the amount of debt around being a
dentist is
it's it's mind-blowing in general
and in that in the community that your
wife works
walks in every day uh a million dollars
or a half million dollars in debt for
the rest of your life
is not unusual it's standard
and you can get sucked into that
paradigm and i'm gonna challenge you not
to
i'm gonna challenge you to get this paid
off like it was a credit card
like you were ashamed of this debt you
follow me
yeah don't normalize it and keep it like
it's a dadgum pet
so limit the size of it this year by
saving everything you get your hands on
and then get
into um attack mode and
finish and take out as a small loan as
you can then take that loan out
and it sounds to me like you can take
that loan out in uh 12 to 18 months from
the time you
it's gonna be a very short period of
time if you guys won't go back and act
like now i'm a rich dentist or something
i i did some research back in grad
school on the mental health of doctors
and physicians and nurses
and one of the worst subgroups was
dentists and i have to
wonder high rate of show hi we'll have
to wonder if it's
this crushing debt that you just carry
around and carry around that's normed in
that community more so than some of
these other
communities yeah the um
borrowed future podcast that we did we
interviewed a dentist that had over a
million dollars in debt
and student loans yeah yeah and the guy
was just crying yeah
he was just crying because you can't you
can't clean your teeth you can't clean
your way out of that right
yeah well you can but it's just i mean
but it takes one you've got to have a
you gotta have a certain level of
and you gotta you gotta have some
specialization in the thing or you gotta
have some volume or something
to get the income up but it sounds like
she's gonna be making
uh out of the uh i'm i don't know but i
mean you sound like she's gonna be
making
chunk of money quarter million dollars a
year her part so
um yeah let's use that let's use
everything we can to
to limit this and then when you don't
have any payments in the world and
you're making 350.
now you're in the agreement to do all
kinds of things right and it does change
the way you operate a business it
changes the way you view going to work
it changes when you own a practice or
you own a business when you get the debt
off of you it it the borrower's slave
the lender it changes the way you stand
the way you walk the way you carry
yourself dustin is in naples florida hi
dustin welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave how are you great man how can we
help
my wife and i are on baby step number
two with
baby number two on the way um
and we have uh we currently have a hour
commute
and we're wondering if we should sell
our house to move closer to work we
don't work at the same
company uh yes
but you may be renting yes
that's what we plan to do we plan to
rent until
we get out of baby step two three and
save up our down payment
yeah so how much closer can you move to
work
well we can move maybe two minutes away
yeah
and so you're going to get two hours of
your life times two parents
four out four hours of parenting
returned
to you rather than in the car every day
absolutely i'm doing this i'd do it
today yes
yeah i have an 11 minute commute um
and if there's no traffic less
but that would be illegal but um
but uh yeah so i i you know i don't want
to spend my life
doing that a lot of people do and it's
normalized and some people redeem the
time with
audio books and other things and there's
all kinds of ways you can do it if you
have a commute commute's normal in a lot
of large metro areas
but um it is a decision that you're
making and you ought to make it
intentionally and if you can
change it and get more sections of your
life back i highly recommend you do
not to mention you cut your your debt
load back that i mean you're going to
find yourself with
less stress and four hours of your life
back man that's a that's a big
turnaround for your whole home
yeah the the level of uh simply the
amount of sleep you're getting will
change
man sleep the ability to just have
conversations with your spouse
ability to be present with your kids oh
that's kind of well they're in the car
an hour a day they got the opportunity
for conversation they're trapped but
but yeah but he's just yeah that's uh
if you're in an area naples is an area
where you don't have to
do a one-hour commute in order to just
have a job and be able to have a place
to live then and yeah
i'm i always encourage that now
for those of you listening out there
that is not to say you move
up in-house into a more expensive house
well the homes in the neighborhood in my
experience
uh well then you maybe can't make that
move right or save your money you need
to move a lateral move
down and or become a renter right for a
period of time to get your finances
under control don't
use this as an excuse to go to
an increase in debt an increase in house
price purchase and
um you know
john the um with personal finance being
80
behavior 20 head knowledge the behavior
aspects having you around to talk about
this stuff
is um has been uh
it's been helpful very helpful but the
uh uh
the power of the human mind to
rationalize
and to to do something stupid and figure
out a way and twist it in our brain to
where they it sounds smart
yeah we we will find what we are looking
for
and if i find a a way the math works in
my favor
i will champion that if i find the way i
can make this my wife's fault not mine i
will
champion it if i can find a way to hear
what dave ramsey just told he told me to
sell the house and move
and buy double the price in town he
heard him yeah
right we'll find a way to to lie to
ourselves to make that happen
we have a hard time telling ourselves
the truth here i don't know if a guy
drove two miles to work two miles and
bought a thirty thousand dollar pickup
because his old pickup that was paid for
in the driveway
that didn't get good gas mileage get a
bike didn't get good gas mileage get a
bike
right you could have to throw that new
truck to the moon and back
to get enough gas mileage to pay for it
that's somebody who lied to himself
so he could get a new truck that's
exactly right that's what i'm talking
about
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
caleb is with us hey caleb how are you
man i'm excellent how are you
better than i deserve welcome where do
you live fort worth texas oh good for
you
john always uh connects up with the
texans
there we go so uh how much data have you
paid off brother one hundred and ten
thousand dollars uh what is one hundred
and ten thousand six hundred ninety five
dollars in two cents to be excellent
how long have you how long did this take
46 months wow and your range of income
60 000 to 72 000. cool what do you do
for a living
high school band director all right good
for you yeah kind of debt was the 111 a
little bit everything uh
undergrad graduate interest on those
student loans uh credit cards uh
car french horn and then a loan from the
bank of mom and dad
ooh everybody's in line yeah everybody
you had a long line too
the french horn debtors are fierce right
dude
[Laughter]
so what happened 46 months ago to lit
you up man i was in grad school
already deep in more debt and one of my
friends put on her facebook that she
read this book called
total money makeover and it sparked my
interest
i reached out to her and then i got the
book actually in january of 2016
and it was really stressful because i
didn't have an income
so i wanted to do all these things but i
had to wait until i had a full income
so for about six to seven months i was
living off of my student loans like
agonizing waiting for a real job to
finish school and get an income to get
going on it so
soon as you hit the ground after school
you took off yeah over 2000 bucks a
month
i did everything in the book to to pay
it off quickly man
amazing congratulations thank you that
was a big mountain to climb
yeah a lot of vacations that i didn't go
on or things that i didn't buy
uh a old truck that i kept way too long
yeah almost four years
yeah and and so you're what in your late
20s how old are you oh
yeah we'll go with that no i'm 30 31.
okay 31. well close enough yeah
and so uh yeah like you're everybody
that your friends
are out doing all kinds of stuff and
you're working to get out of debt
yeah a lot of my friends would go on
vacations or even if i could go on like
a wedding trip
um i wouldn't do the extra things that
they were all out doing i was just happy
to be at the wedding and you know
pay for the rental tux but it's like hey
we're going rafting it's like
i got to say no at some point guys i got
to pay off my date eventually so
yeah way to go so band directors are
similar to football coaches right
especially in texas you're yeah you're
inspiring young people you're getting
them to
to think to understand they're bigger
than
they have bigger dreams they can
accomplish more than they thought they
had they go past limitations
how has this journey impacted how you
impact
high school kids this is a metaphor uh a
lot of my students will like kind of
laughingly roll their eyes but this this
has become a metaphor and one of my
students when i was teaching in houston
suggested that i start a youtube channel
so i would just make little youtube
videos about how to budget how to think
about money
um the future millionaire band director
uh it's got 800 subscribers dave
watching all right
and thank you man that's true i like the
title too yes
i like the title a lot and so that kind
of now i'm doing like a little mini
series about
like getting students ready for college
and what kind of questions to ask how to
go to college for free there are still
music scholarships out there things like
that
we're gonna double your subscription
today let's hope so so uh
tell everybody again what's the youtube
channel what's it called the future
millionaire band director all right
everybody go sign up and watch it it's
got everything it's got high school band
it's got college advice and financial
advice
i mean what more could you want nothing
that's awesome man way to go very cool
so now that i mean the the impressive
part about your numbers not only the
height and the amount which is
huge that you knocked out but the fact
you stick with something
46 freaking months most people in
america can't stick with something 46
seconds
they can't be married 46 months how did
you do this man well
my twin sister always says that i'm like
super obsessive when i do something i
just jump like
all in and uh this is one of those
things that i became obsessive about um
when i was living in houston my family's
from dfw so i would drive to see them
listening to the podcast obsessing over
my every dollar budget like where can i
where can i like shrink the budget where
can i fix it and uh
what habit do i need to change can i
carpool to work do i need to move out
into a bigger rent house so i can pick
up another roommate to lower the rent it
was like
every part of the budget got a good look
at least once
once or twice a week to figure out how
to you know scrape some off
yeah you went truly gazelle intense that
obsessive idea this thing i'm going
i'm gonna do this and really i'm gonna
put the blinders on and you really don't
hear
the negative voices much when you get
that fired up yeah i was fortunate
enough that my family was like
you're crazy but go for it in your hours
yeah yeah you are crazy and uh my uh my
students were also super supportive like
any time i would bring my lunch and be
like i look at you mr shoe like you're
taking care of your
your finances and all it was it was
really cool yeah way to go man
so someone coming out of grad school
with a pile of debt right now
like you did 46 months ago is listening
what do you tell them the secret to
getting out of that is i remember
reading
one of the chapters of your book and it
was for me i had to first understand
that debt wasn't a tool
i used to tell my students like way back
in the day that you you had to take out
student loans if you wanted to use that
as an investment in your future
and because i thought debt was a tool to
get you somewhere and i
i think that if anybody's going to pay
off their debt they're going to
understand that first and foremost debt
is not a tool
and if they don't understand that
concept they will never get out of the
gate even
and i've got a lot of friends who say
that they're going to pay off their car
or their credit card
but i'm going to keep my student loans
for forever i i have friends who have
told me that they're just going to be in
debt for the rest of their life
so they have to understand first and
foremost the debt is not a tool
it's an anchor yeah yeah that's a big
one that's a big one
and so and then you said you know you
were obsessive and that's what enabled
you to persevere and stick with
something almost four years
that's so impressive so impressive very
cool i'm so proud of you man
well done very very well done who were
your biggest cheerleaders
oh for sure my my dad was always super
supportive my family was really really
supportive even if they were making fun
of me
um my coworkers who i went to work with
every day you know we would go out to
lunch once a week and sometimes i would
not have budget anymore to go out to
lunch and so i would just bring my lunch
to wherever we went out to eat and they
were always super supportive my students
gave me lots of positive vibes my
boyfriend was super supportive
of the whole thing and so now anytime i
offer to buy dinner he's always super
he's shocked he's like oh we're going to
loosen the budget a little bit for that
well well done sir very very proud i'm
proud of you man great job thank you we
got a copy of chris hogan's book for you
everyday millionaires and that
definitely is the next
chapter in your story so we're excited
for you well
done well done caleb from fort worth
texas
a hundred and eleven thousand dollars
paid off in 46 months
making 60 to 72 000 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one i'm debt-free
[Music]
[Applause]
well done well done well done great job
man
that's a that's a lot of money over a
long
period of time 46 months
and i got to tell you man he's right you
do have to become obsessive that was
really good
a really good analysis on his part 46
months dave people can't
it's we're at the end of january 99
of americans quit their uh new year's
resolutions already right yep
and i just made that stat up by the way
because it supported what i was trying
to say here
but you just keep going 88 percent of
the statistics are made up that's right
but you just keep going and going and
going what a
way to persevere you know i i remember
the first time
i ever um actually went in a gym and got
a personal trainer many many years ago i
would have loved to have been there for
that yeah
you wouldn't have either it was just it
was ugly it was really ugly
and uh but he's you know we couldn't get
on the treadmill and stuff because
there's too many people right we
couldn't cut it the machines were busy
everything's busy busy busy
and uh it's like it's right now it's
like second third week of january and he
goes
don't worry about it valentine's day
they'll all be gone it'll be gone it's
the valentine's day curse
45 days the gym is empty again
people can't stick away the 45 days 46
months wow you know caleb stuck with
this and i liked what he said about
it's all of it it was the personal
decision to listen to things and then to
practice and then to have accountability
and have friends and have
students who are watching him to make
sure it was all of that all together
yeah right it's everything it's not just
one thing or this thing or one big great
new rodney speech and then you're like
i'm char it's all of it over and over
and over again
the the it is a marathon it is not a
sprint
and uh the good news about someone who's
done it like he like caleb did is he he
will never go back
no man it's over he's you to stick with
it 46 months you have to be changed
inside love it not just have a a cursory
drive by with the ideas
and he gave a picture to how who knows
how many
young people that's what sacrifice looks
like that's what bringing your lunch
looks like that's what that old truck
looks like amen and they got a new
picture of what debt free living can
look like
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america this is
the dave ramsey show open phones at
eight two five five two two five dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today fred is with us fred is in idaho
falls
idaho hey fred what's up
hey what's your recommendation for
long-term care insurance you usually
recommend it at 60
statistics or you know history you
probably wouldn't use it
for 20 plus years should you invest that
premium money into a good growth account
and ensure yourself insured well let me
pull up my cheat sheet here on your
statistics because they're wrong
um but i don't have memorized so i'm
going to flip through my cheat sheet
here
seventy percent of the people over 65
will require some type of long-term care
before their death seven out of ten
americans will spend some time in a
nursing home
uh at some point um
so i uh the numbers that i have seen and
i don't have them on this cheat sheet
but
um let's see here maybe
see if i can find anything here uh the
average age of a claimant is 79 to your
point
um so uh 71
of claimants are women um 51
are due to cognitive issues that was a
new one i hadn't seen before okay
so uh the numbers that i've seen and
they're not on this sheet
and so i'm doing this from memory fred
are that uh
it's less than one half of one percent
of the people prior to 60
use nursing homes and so never buy a
long-term care insurance
and policy until you're 60. but when i
looked at the stats
the reason i came up with that number
was or the reason i came up with that as
my guideline for folks
because i do believe in long-term care
insurance unless you have 5 million
or more in net worth because you can
self-insure then
but i i uh that the percentage
increased likelihood of use of a nursing
home after age 60 the percentage
increase
the graph was such a steep curve like
every minute
you're over 60 your your your
chances of going increase dramatically
and so
if you have a substantial net worth over
60 like 25 million plus you'd
self-insure
but otherwise i'm going to tell you to
get a policy uh
but you're you would be right the older
you get the higher the likelihood is
you're going to use it and that
my cheat sheet says the average age of
someone using it is 79.
the other thing that can happen in your
60s even if you're not using it until
your 70s
is you have a higher probability of
losing your health
just due to getting old and thereby not
qualifying to get a policy
that's what i was wondering is it
cheaper to buy in if you buy into the
younger age
that's why people want people to do it
40. you know yeah it's much
cheaper to buy at 40 or 50. but your
likelihood of using it is so
low it doesn't the premiums don't offset
so it doesn't work out so
insurance companies are pretty good at
math they they do a good job about
figuring out that premium
is if if you have an insurance premium
that's cheap there's a reason it's a
very low probability of the event
happening whatever the event is right
and so it doesn't cost much well there's
because it ain't going to happen right i
mean that's what you're looking at so
uh statistically i remember clearly the
conversation my parents and i had when
they told us i think it was for
christmas that's what we got for
christmas
they gave you a long-term care policy
themselves
and that was giving you a gift and it
was we all it was just this
whoo right because because me and my
brother and sister had talked about it
hey what's gonna happen if
and we had talked to my dad and my mom
about it and they circled up and said
it's
it's it's gonna lean on us a little bit
budget wise
but it's the right thing to do and it
was a gift yeah yeah it is
and 70 of the
uh ladies outlive their husbands and
uh so if you're listening out there
married couple ladies the typical
scenario this that's tragic
is papa goes in the nursing home there's
200 000 in savings he burns through it
cracks and scrambles the nest egg and
dies
yep and then mama's left to live 10 more
years with no money
right because it all went to the nursing
home yeah and so that's why you get
long-term care and trial
insurance policies it's for you ladies
actually statistically speaking anyway
and yet the highest number of claimants
is female
but that also would be after their
husband pre-deceases them
75 of those with pre-deceased their
wives that makes sense because when i
used to visit my
grandparents in the nursing home there's
always that guy
so he's must be in the other percent
right the one guy that just thinks
he's casanova he's a rare bird yeah
he's waving that cane around like he's
attending a girl girls college and got
in yeah he's got it made
he's gonna say brother you are not that
handsome
no he's just rare which is also an
advantage
if you don't have the other one john's
with us in louisville kentucky hey john
how are you
hey bro sure okay
i'll just get to the point here real
quick um
my son needs braces if we pay the braces
up
front we will save 500
okay out of 4 600 so we'll pay it'll be
able to pay for 4100
now we have thirty seven hundred dollars
in savings
we have forty five hundred dollars in
the bank so we could pay for that cash
now she wants to pay for it to save the
five hundred dollars
i don't wanna i wanna pay the thousand
dollars and then we can make i think
it's 188
payments for 20 months because
my furnace is 17 years old and my car
it has almost 300 000 miles on it and i
drive
27 miles one way every day
and i i just need some room
okay well um
i've been doing the show 28 years i've
never told anybody borrow money yet
and this is borrowing money
so um this is borrowing money yes i got
to tell her she's right
if you want me to blow the whistle and
throw the flag i can but um
yeah but you're right too i mean you've
got some valid concerns there so how do
we
what are some ways we can look at how we
get to these other issues the furnace
and the car
uh because we're taking you dangerously
low on cash and so
if we're going to do this uh for this
child
now and not wait six months which
probably wouldn't be the end of the
world if you did i'm not
i'm not an expert on dentistry but i
suspect they would
probably still be able to straighten
their teeth if you wait six months
and um which might be a plan and during
that six months pile up some more cash
to
where it gives all of you some more
comfort uh that's
probably what the ramses would have done
but if you don't do that then what we do
have to do is we have to put the house
on the whole home
on beans and rice rice and beans as if
you had a bunch of credit card debt or
something
and you're being gazelle intense because
you've got some known
things coming at you so your analysis of
that is correct i mean that furnace is
going to go out and that car's going to
go
there's not any question in your mind or
my mind i just don't know when
it's not a matter of if it's just when
is it six months or is it 18 months
but it's not it's not eight years you
know
i never even thought about waiting i
mean it sounds silly i never thought
about waiting six months
he's 11 and a half he's got all this
permanent teeth i've never thought about
waiting six months
i'm sure the doctor is going to tell you
that i'm a quack because when it comes
to dentistry i am i have no
qualifications whatsoever
except i'm a dad that bought a couple of
sets of braces over the years
i did i did do the same exact analysis
and
they um they make it almost sound like
you're not borrowing money it's more
like you're renting
these braces but they'll give you a
discount for paying the rental up front
like they're gonna re-rent them after
you give them back but anyway i don't
know
but it's uh to me i looked at it with
our two that had braces as debt and i
just prepaid it like your wife is
suggesting
but i think that means that we have to
look at
there's three valid things that need to
occur here
furnace car braces and we've got to
treat all of them like they're very
important
because they are and john i i need
you didn't ask for this but i just got
to speak it out there i know the tension
i feel when i want to buy something when
i have to buy something and then my wife
says hey
hank needs shoes and the temptation is
to let him know
i'm buying you these shoes at a cost of
right
and so the temptation is going to take
that boy you better appreciate that
i'm driving this truck because and what
i'm going to ask you to do is don't put
that
in the heart and soul of your 11 year
old that he's a burden to his family
that dad can't drive to work or we can't
have heat and
john doesn't say that and you said i
know he didn't i know he didn't make
sure he doesn't yeah
if everybody out there man take care of
your kids because that's the right thing
to do and don't
don't make them feel more of a burden
they already do yeah
amen good stuff
be kind and unified and you know dave
stop with your propaganda just kind of
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i am dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us dr john dolone ramsey personality is
my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two
five chad starts off this hour in provo
utah hi chad welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi johnny dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um so my question is we're
we're fairly new to the baby steps we've
known about them for a long time
but we're currently on baby step number
two um we own a duplex that we used to
live in
and um if we were to sell that
we would be able to go straight from
baby step two to baby step
four five and six um but i do have a few
reservations about that and so i'm just
wondering
what would you what would you do in my
situation we don't recommend folks sell
their homes
uh to get out of debt unless they're
going to sell them anyway
uh we do we we own another home that we
live in currently
so we used to live in this duplex it's a
rental
it's a rental now we moved out about
five years ago
and held on to it the plan was to just
keep it
and use it as an investment property
right
okay and so how much debt do you have uh
let's be currently about
seventy five thousand dollars what's
your household income
household income is around ninety
thousand dollars okay
well what about 95 with the with the
income from the properties
let's just take a set of scales and put
the rental house on one side
of the scales and the number of years
that it's going to take you to pay off
75 000 making 90 which is
two years okay
no more than that so do you want to fast
forward your get out of debt plan
by two years badly enough to sell the
duplex
there's not really a wrong answer here
because you can get out of that fast
enough if you want to keep it you can
keep it
but you might want to be out of debt
more than you want the duplex and that
would be not a wrong answer too
right and that's that's kind of what
we're looking at um one of the things
that we have going on my wife uh works
as a cosmetologist
hairdresser and so she's taken a hit
this year here in utah she's been able
to work but anytime she
is filling under the weather or a client
is filling under the weather they
basically have to cancel
so income goes down there
also we have a daughter that last year
was diagnosed with type 1 diabetes and
so
we're fully funding on our hsa so that
takes
you know some of our uh money there
um and so so do you want to do you want
to sell the house
i i kind of do some of the reservations
i have
are um you know it'd be nice to be out
move on be in you know those later steps
but possibly you know having that
physical asset
that is kind of a hedge against
inflation and we don't know what all the
printing of money is going to do whether
or not there's going to be some major
inflation that goes with that
um okay all the things that you know
about your life
and all the things that you perceive
about the future
which of these two avenues gives you
the best life than the most
wealth 10 years from today
i and and that i don't know i i i go
back and forth
i can tell you don't come through that's
how you're going to answer that that's
how you're going to have to answer the
question
you know every decision has some pluses
and minuses there are a few decisions
that don't have some
minuses and you can make a list of the
pros and the cons on keeping the duplex
a list of the pros and cons of selling
the duplex and getting out of debt
um i think i hear that the reasons that
you bought that you wanted to own real
estate in the first place are the only
reasons you're trying to keep it
even though your whole situation has
changed
and you stuck with your old i think you
stuck with your old reasoning
and that and you're trying to use that
in your current reasoning
and so i think i think you're selling
the duplex
but i'm okay dave ramsey's okay with you
doing either one if you want to
roll up your sleeves buckle down and in
the midst of the diabetes in the midst
of the
irregular income ho in order to hold on
to it
and fight through the debt and get rid
of it in the next two years and be on
beans and rice for two years there's
nothing wrong with doing that
it's not against our plan you know so
you go do what you want to do
i i and and again i i'm somebody who
would
want to sleep at night and knowing my my
daughter's clear
my irregular income we can weather that
because i don't know anybody anything in
the world
right but i think it comes down to a
risk tolerance right and exactly what it
is beans and rice
i find this a lot that um especially
people who are
tend to be more anxious tend to be more
control oriented
man you can project into the unknown
mysterious future any norm number of
wild scenarios man and they can paralyze
you in the present
and you just got to sit down and make
some decisions once you make it go for
it
yeah i think you're selling it because i
think you're going to get more peace
that way
and i think you're probably going to end
up with more money that way
at the end of the day and are we going
to have hell to pay with all these
trillions of dollars yep right someday
we are
right i mean i i'm i have a lot of
people in my world i have
you know when they get to the end of
their career they write the world's
coming to an end book
of course and i'm not going to write
that book i promised myself long ago
so the world is going to come to an end
but i will not be predicting it
and that includes all of this ridiculous
debt that congress has continued to pile
up
my entire life and it's unbelievable and
yes
eventually there's going to be some kind
of a reckoning but
give yourself peace now i remember
reading the book bankruptcy 1984.
uh no 1994 1994. that was a book that
came out it's scary to death
yeah i thought the whole well i mean it
was a it was a you know a scientific
detailed economic with proven
great economic minds that the uh that
the hockey stick of debt was going to
crash the
economy in the year 1994.
probably can't even find a copy of that
book now no
you can there's one on my shelf i kept
it because i wanted to remember
not to write that book i think
i think it was uh nasim tilleb it says
everybody's throwing darts backwards and
somebody hits and they turn into the
hero of the
super predictor of the world right yeah
eventually enough people throw a dart
backwards you're gonna
told you so yeah and you can never do it
again yeah right yeah it's
it's not a repeatable act right so um
anyway all that to say um if i woke up
in your shoes what would i do
i love rental property probably more
than you do
and i would sell it because i would want
the freedom
faster and it just because you sell this
rental property doesn't mean you can't
save up and pay cash for another rental
property later and it's a lot more peace
right
later in your journey and it's not like
you're gonna lose the ability to ever
own hard assets or
ever own dirt and bricks and mortar and
um you know
if i were in your shoes i'd be done with
it
but it you know as a matter of course on
the show and giving advice
i don't you know if it was a car i'd
sell in heartbeat
but it's a stupid but it's a rental
property and there's some reasons to
continue to fight for it if you want to
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host
today here on the air this is the dave
ramsey show our question today comes
from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsay to get the
best possible
deal today's question comes from lisa in
kentucky
she writes my husband and i are debt
free the house that we live in was
purchased as a gift to us from his
parents
the house is completely paid for however
there's always a however dave
the house is not in our name i do not
feel secure without the house being in
our name
we have a great relationship and i trust
my in-laws but i have an issue with this
what should i do so my first
thought here dave is if somebody buys a
house for you and gives it to you but
it's not in your name it's not your
house
is that a poor way to look at that no
it's not like they bought a house and
letting you live in it no
there's not it's not a gift until it's
in your name there you go
so is it out of line here to have that
conversation
yeah i and i think the way you always
have a
conversation like that is it's very very
important to
put a lot of icing on the cake before
you start talking about this
and the icing the a lot of sweetness yup
and that's gratitude
absolutely how grateful you are and i
would never want to seem ungrateful and
we're not ungrateful and we are so
thankful and so forth
um it does make us uncomfortable that
it's not in our name
and we want to know when we're going to
get it into our name or
we're getting a will done and we need to
make sure all these assets flow in a
certain place
that's fine but but bottom line is is
that
this is weird yeah yeah i would not give
my kids a house
and leave it in my name okay yeah it's
just
because then it's not their house it's
their house yeah i mean
let me give you an example okay um
her father-in-law is uh working second
shift
and he falls asleep at the wheel and he
uh
goes across the center line hits
somebody and a kid is killed on the
other car
they're taking that house too taking
that house that's right because it's his
asset
when they sue him for 500 million
dollars the judgment lien will be on
the house that is not hers right
and that's called an accident right that
i described absolutely the father-in-law
did anything wrong
i didn't call him a drunk he wasn't
drunk driving i didn't call him anything
i didn't say anything negative about him
right
but it's just you know he could you know
he could
have a business go bad and get an rs
lien and
guess what the irs lane is on all of his
assets right and this house is his asset
not hers right so and the other piece of
advice i would just give you is
um uh uh you don't talk
let your husband talk it's his parents
you can sit there
with a smile on your face and the only
thing you're allowed to say is how
grateful you are
right i want you to know how grateful
you are right and you're not allowed to
make the uh mic body language or
grimaces
or words that are part of
this conversation that has at its
essence conflict in it
because you're going to get labeled as
the cause of it ah
you're gonna be labeled as the
dissension but in the family yeah right
yeah the
evil uh it would have been okay if it's
my son but his wife got involved
there you go so they say something along
the lines of well
we will we're not comfortable doing that
now
but we will in my head i immediately
switched to this isn't our house
we we are living rent-free in my parents
house we now are saving up for our own
place yep
and then i'm off to the races there
exactly i'm going to use i'm not going
to
sleep over it thank you thank you for
the free rent and i'm going to use that
to save up and buy my own house
i'm not going to throw a fit about it
i'm not going to whine about it we're
going to go buy ourselves a house
yeah well you said it was a gift we're
moving on we're moving on we're just
going to
look if you're not going to put it in my
name it's not a gift you got to have
that clear
logic in your head so the other thing
about this lisa
is is that you want you need to hear
loud and clear from john we're saying
you're right
absolutely yes you're right you're not
crazy this has got some weirdness on it
there's something weird here
and i don't know what it is it may be a
simple thing that they've they haven't
had good
tax planning that nobody showed them how
to do it without getting it without
getting a
gift tax bill because you know if
they'll see a good tax planner they can
teach them how to do
uh to transfer an asset that size as a
gift without having any gift tax
under the unified estate gift tax credit
and it's one piece of paper with their
filing of their taxes this year and
unless they have an estate over 20
million dollars it won't affect their
state taxes a time
so um there's lots of ways to do this
they may just not know how to do it
and there's you know but but if that's
the only reason but
i'm gonna guess and say that's not the
reason i know something about this field
ziki dave
yep but yep yep yep and it is the
daughter-in-law asking
right isn't it interesting that the son
didn't ask the question
he's the guy i want to talk to in this
yeah he's the one he's because he's the
one going
through the talking right if this is
handled properly
he needs deal with his mama not his wife
dealing with his mama yes
because i can just tell you this is how
this is going to go down do you feel
like paying off your debt is going to
take forever well it's a new year
and uh paying off your debt won't take
forever we can show you how we do it all
the time it's what we do here ramsay
plus is where
you get out of debt faster you'll become
debt free
you'll be spending money without worry
you're going to be building wealth
you're going to be outrageously generous
we're going to show you how to do all of
it there are three apps that work
together
to help you pay off your debt as fast as
possible of course that includes
financial peace university
of course that includes the baby steps
tracker of course that includes every
dollar premium
of course it includes a whole bunch of
other stuff we're going to show you step
by step
day by day what to do for the first 90
days and you get a free trial at ramsey
plus
by texting trial to 33
789 trial 233 789
jackson is in oklahoma city hey jackson
what's up
hi there how's it going better than i
deserve how can i help
so i'm going to be moving to florida in
two days i currently live in oklahoma
um i'm going to be doing work for my
girlfriend's parents being a roofing
company
down in florida um and i'm estimating to
make between
five and nine thousand a month you know
it's a sales job so it's kind of
it's kind of a rough average um i have
about five thousand
currently in savings and then so
estimate i'll come back roughly with 20
000
after the three months that would give
me 25 000 to put down i was thinking
about
putting down on a duplex um and then
renting out the other side
to get some income paid for that
mortgage um
do you think i should hold on and still
work a little bit more and save some
more money or whenever i come back
based on that number purchase a duplex
yeah i would just wait
i appreciate the idea that you're trying
to create some assets and trying to
create um
you know a baseline here to start to
grow your wealth
um but number one i want you out of dad
do you have any debt
um i have a car loan yeah you need to
pay that offer about
3 000 left on that so i mean i can go
ahead and pay it off and
you think i should do that now well as
soon as you make the move one of the two
as soon as you get your first check in
let's get that cleared up
and then you need an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses
and then if you buy a duplex and
18 months later are married to this girl
you're going to sell the duplex
and buy a house that she wants to live
in because she's not going to live there
and so instead i would just short
circuit that and let's wait
and pile up the cash for after the
marriage to buy a house
okay and then i also have um about eight
thousand dollars in a mutual fund
and then four thousand and just uh like
a robin hood account that i've been
investing in
today okay and then whenever i go to
purchase a house do you think i should
liquidate that and then use that as a
down payment or go and keep those in
there yeah you have your
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses in a simple savings account
just for rainy days and then everything
else is going down on this house because
what the goal is to pay the house off as
fast as possible after you buy it
okay well the main reason i was thinking
about duplex is i wanted to hold on to
it and then use as a rental property
down the road but you think i should go
and skip that and just purchase a home
yep yep yep i want you to get some
rental property later
but i don't want debt on the rental
property and um
and i don't want you learning to be a
landlord while you're learning a new job
and while you're dating the boss's
daughter
yeah i don't want you counting any
future dollars that you're earning from
the father of your girlfriend that just
man
you're set yourself up for triple
heartbreak brother there's
so many things can go wrong here and
when they go wrong they're all going to
go wrong
it just slipped off the roof officer i
don't know what happened
so yeah brothers yeah let's count those
checks after they're in your hand man
yeah yeah good it sounds fun sound like
you got an adventure ahead of you
yeah oh that's the most passive
aggressive thing i heard you say today
dave
that's an adventure yeah i would tell
you crazy what you are
it's gonna work out it's gonna be
awesome it'll be good it's gonna be
awesome
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the dave ramsey
show thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five rob is with us rob's in atlanta
georgia hey rob how are you
hey dave dr d how are you guys doing
great man how can we help
i am on baby step seven praise god for
that
um me and my wife uh we've
i've always been the nerd she's always
been the free spirit i've found
we are on baby step 7 by the way thank
you jack um but
i've always found that um i'm only
we've led financial peace university
probably close to a dozen times
but i just recently found some like
credit card that she had
had that i didn't know about nothing's
on them necessarily
um i've always kind of had to
drag her to the meetings and stuff like
that
and i know oftentimes the answer for
this is go to counseling we've been
to counseling we've been married 26
years been counseling many times and
her ultimate response to all of it is
you are who you are i am who i am and i
don't see the point going any
further much so i'm kind of had a am i
just
since we're on baby step seven that she
has a a job as well that uh
she does that we don't incorporate into
the regular budget she does kind of her
own self-care like hair and nails and
stuff like that
um just never been completely on the
same page but will have
great success ultimately so just need
some guidance
looking for some guidance from you guys
yeah brother this isn't a baby step
question this is a
um you all are on two different pages
man and
this i can't imagine this isn't showing
up in other places in your relationship
besides just financially
where else does this show up
uh well i mean we're not we are on the
same page you know
in so many ways spiritually parenting
sexually
things like that so so it's just money
she says you be you and i'll be me i'll
keep my paycheck you pay for the rest of
the house
i'll take care of me i'm gonna hide
stuff and be deceptive even though i
know you're out
like leading classes on how people can
live whole connected lives
everything else is is just above board
and all good
yeah i mean we have a very healthy
marriage so here's what i'm telling you
outside of you
you don't it's not as healthy as you
think it is
and i i mean if i'm the first guy to
tell you that i i'm ashamed of the the
counselors y'all have worked with
um ashamed of your connect your
community that surrounds you guys
but there's some deeper rooted issues
here because this is something that
means a lot to you
that you've put on the block that you've
gone up and presented yourself in a
certain way
to your community members to your church
to your friends to your family
and she's gone behind your back and been
deceptive
that tells me there's deeper cracks in
this thing or just straight up
boat up her back and said screw you i'm
gonna do whatever i want to do
i mean that's the message you got it's
message i heard
right yeah i i'm a grown up i have the
right to do whatever i want to do
and our you know the fact that that is
contrary to everything you believe
doesn't matter i'm gonna do whatever i
want
and um it's not about whether you have a
credit card or not it's about the
disconnection
yes this is about about marriage i mean
if um you're not on the same page
and uh it's there's a level of um
the disrespect here that that and uh
you know if you were doing this to her
it'd be the same thing i mean if
and so i i you know
i don't know john i mean he he he said
you know more counseling but i don't
think
more counseling he's going to do good so
i i don't know what do you do
to me you sit down and yeah yeah
she's not being fully known and he's not
being fully known they're not
being fully honest with one another and
the temptation here is he's trying to
measure the success of his marriage by
the the size of his bank account and
that's not how that works man you can
have a remarkable marriage
without seven figures in the bank and
you can have a train wreck of a marriage
or marriage number six or seven or eight
with seven figures in the bank and at
some point you have to sit down and say
i'm gonna have to put all the cards on
the table i'm heartbroken over this
and i need to know what else is there
because i i've nev this will be the
first time i've ever heard
of everything firing on all cylinders in
a relationship
and somebody's saying but i'm just i'm
gonna lie to you and deceive you and not
do this thing over here
but everywhere else it's okay that's
just how that works man
so there's something there that people
aren't incongruent in one area and
congruent in other areas
not that not that sharply right yeah um
and so there's something else here
you're right if she says i'm not going
to counseling
what you may want to do is go on your
own yeah and say i need to work on
myself because that's all you can
control in this moment you can't fix her
you can't solve her you can't help her
um she's going to have to want to be
plugged in here too and a good counselor
can coach you on how to interact
right differently than you ever have
before maybe
yeah it creates a different result and
without talking to her there may be
things that
you know that rob you're bringing to the
table that make you not a safe place for
her to come home to that make her have
to hide stuff because you're somebody
that flies off the handle you are
filling the blank fill in the blanket so
i don't want to dump all this on her but
what i'm telling you is
man it would be the first of my of my
experience that you guys are
just humming along except for this one
place where she lies to you
and is just completely dismissed
abstinent yeah
yeah yeah that's just that's strange
yeah
hey thanks for the call that's hard work
i could be more help but so the the
recommendation you were right rob
is more counseling that you get a
different one and someone that's a
little more bold
uh and that calls you out on your stuff
and also trains you
up on how to interact with her to draw
her back into the conversation again
because couples who look at each other
and say yeah
you do you i'll do me this is not a
couple
this is a roommate right yeah it's a
business partner and y'all done well as
a business community way to go man
you made some money yeah sage is with us
sage is in tallahassee florida hi sage
how are you
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up
okay my husband's job is ending um
probably in about four months and
we have um about 58
000 in cash and about 180 000
in our 401k and about 20 000
in stock we are completely out of debt
except for our home um
we have paid a hundred thousand dollars
of it off this
uh last year so i'm down to the 167
000. my question is he's 63
so since he's losing his job we're
wondering if it would be smart to take
our 401k
and pay our house off
if you had more money i would but it's
going to drain you down to almost
nothing
because by the time you're going to have
to pay the taxes on that 401k and by the
time you do that
i mean he's over 59 and a half so he
doesn't have any penalty but you have
taxes on it
so if you told me it's 600 000 in there
i'd say yeah i'll do it pay the taxes on
that much and pay off the house today
but you're going to end up with no nest
egg and a paid-for house
well i have a uh rental house that's
completely paid for
that my elderly parents uh live in and
so i do have
rent from that once they are you know no
longer with us
that house right now is worth about
probably 350 000.
okay so it gives you that gives you a
little less tag that's helpful but still
uh how old are they
uh during their late 80s okay
well i i and not in the best of health
yeah i don't i don't want to set up a
scenario
by paying off the house with your only
cash money that you've got
not counting this piece of real estate
that puts you in a position that your
parents have to die for you to be okay
money-wise
that ultimately is going to happen we
all know that but
i don't want you to be i don't want to
be financially wishing for their death
you know so that we can get some money
because we're broke
uh except for this house that they're
living in so i don't want to do that no
i'm not paying off the house today
you don't have enough cash to do that
and and be in a safe place
and your husband's career is not over he
needs to go to work
he's gonna have to go back to work yeah
and it's not done this is not time to
you're not in a position to retire
and i've got two parents that found new
careers in their early 60s
making more money than they did before
doing something
similar or totally different depending
on which one of my parents
is possible but you're gonna have to
suck up your ego and your pride and you
have to go do it
there you go this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
you can join us at triple eight eight
two five five two two five when it comes
to making big money or life changes
like buying a home getting married
having a baby the last
thing on your mind is making sure you
have the right insurance
but maybe it shouldn't be the last thing
hey i get it big changes are
overwhelming
what if not have but if not having the
time or the energy is what's keeping you
from getting the right insurance
coverage
you can use one of our endorsed local
providers for insurance
they are independent agents that means
they don't work for the insurance
company they work for you
and they shop all the different
companies and get the best coverage
at the best price and they'll charge you
anything for that
that's right an independent agent gets
you a deal
it's the only way i buy insurance
so i don't buy from a captive agent who
has one company that they sell for
and of course they're going to tell you
that state farm is the best
when it's not so there you go
i just said that out loud didn't i all
you have to do is text insurance
to 33 789 that's 33789
and get connected with an elp that's
insurance to
33789
all right let's go to rob in portland
maine hey rob welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi dave hi john how are you better than
we deserve what's up
hey i'm at a a big crossroad in my life
i am going to be 47 years old next month
i am also going to be at the 25th year
of my career as a police officer
and eligible for retirement with a 50
pension wow my question to you is
um i'm looking at making a dramatic
train
change in moving from maine to uh middle
tennessee to
um the metro nashville area with my
family my wife
a 16 year old and a 12 year old
and i'm not sure if i'm making the right
decision or not by making that move
i my pension will be approximately
50 000 that i'll have my wife
salary is 60 000 and we're fortunate
enough that she's able to work from home
so she's going to be able to
keep her job and i am looking at
starting all over in law enforcement
down that down there so my
pay hourly will almost be cut in half by
starting all over from what i make now
so i'm just looking for some guidance um
if that's the right thing to do
or if i stay where i'm at i get two
percent
towards my pension for every year i stay
um
why do you want to move that's what i'm
looking at um
well we found middle tennessee because
our oldest boy was stationed at fort
campbell and we visited him quite a bit
he ended up marrying a young lady from
there from hendersonville and
spent a lot of time there and uh liked
it like the school districts
that we saw and
felt that might be a good good change
for us
does it get you excited to think about
moving
it does get me excited to think about
moving what i get less excited about is
starting all over in a career that
i've spent 25 years in
there's nothing financially wrong with
what you're proposing obviously you're
going to have plenty of income
and you won't have any issue living
portland maine i've been there many
times i love it it's a wonderful town
obviously i'm a fan of tennessee i live
in middle tennessee and have my whole
life
and so um you know it's not like you're
downgrading your uh lifestyle or
standard of living or
quality of life um or tremendously
upgrading it because portland's a
quality town
it's not a it's not a drip it's not a
dump it's a good place
and obviously we're a little warmer
weather here um
politics are a lot different than they
are in maine but uh uh
that's another reason to head south yeah
as long as you leave the politics up
there you're welcome
i agree i agree hey so uh rob i i did
this recently
um after my family we packed up and
moved across
across the country and there
is something i i repeat often is the the
best part about moving
is you have a new adventure you gotta
you gotta find new parts of yourself you
get to learn new things and
i i relish that part i like that
challenge the worst part about moving
is that you go with you my marriage
problem stayed the same
my insecurity stayed the same my
waistline didn't suddenly fall off like
all that stuff stayed the same and so
when i got to tennessee
i had to work on those things that i was
having to work on in texas to
and so whatever challenges you and your
wife have or
blessings that you have all that comes
with you right and um
now the common denominator in the story
is you guys that's right
so if you're up for an adventure you're
up for an adventure man um
and if you're not you're not but i i
always say go for it
um but that's just me there's a
tremendous amount of refugees moving
into tennessee
yes they are i saw a great bumper
sticker today it was
from a doctor who just relocated from
california to texas and had a sticker
state of texas and it said do not
california
our state and it was just as blunt as it
could be
so yeah leave it there
amen well hey all that aside uh you've
got the money
uh it sounds like oh the other thing is
um other than the fact that your job is
going to be different forever uh
everything else could be undone right
you could move here
and three years from now move back you
would not be able to move back into your
role
at your old job but so what and so if
you hate it
end the adventure that's exactly right
it doesn't have to be permanent
and theoretically your pension stays put
your wife's job so you can work from
home so you guys have a lot of options
you have a soft cushion to fall on if
this thing goes sideways yeah
and um and there's no requirement that
you take
that type of law enforcement job and
start over at a
big cops rate i've actually my old man
uh had several compadres that would be
in this very same situation
they would work all the way up till
their late 40s when their first kid was
about to go to college
they'd pull their pension and retire and
then they'd go make
35 grand as a college campus police
officer
and all their kids go free oh that's not
so they get their pension
plus a small salary and free tuition all
their kids go to college for free that's
not a bad
game that's a smooth move right not a
bad game at all it's at the right
college you'll be the chief of police on
that that's
it well then you work it through so
you've got all kinds of options right
it's just thinking it's getting your
head around the adventure and i love the
adventure part yeah
yeah i'm up for that part yeah hey good
question thank you for calling in
blessy is with us in detroit michigan
hey blessy what's up
hey dave how are you great how can i
help
so i am 22 years old um
right now and i just graduated last year
in may um and coming out of college i
landed a full-time
uh job i got great and i
yeah um so i saved up
a pretty penny in my bank account uh
right now um
at about 31k um and
i'm kind of wondering um in this sort of
stage in life
a lot of people been telling me that i
should start investing
that money because it's just sitting in
the bank however i don't know what's the
safest
how much money do you have saved i have
about thirty one thousand
okay good well we suggest you and you're
100 debt free right
yes i am good for you we suggest that
you have an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses
and i would set that aside and your
situation i go and sit six
months aside okay because you've done
really well and you've done a great job
saving money
and that's in a separate savings account
never to be touched except for
emergencies that's your rainy day fund
only if something really bad happens do
you touch it okay
it's not i want to buy a couch fund or
go on vacation fund
then the other money you can save past
that you can begin to invest
and we suggest at that point what we
call baby step four where you start
putting
15 percent of your income into
retirement
and and then in and around that as well
you can start saving for your first
house
um and so i would not save any more than
15 percent
to retirement of your income uh
and anything above that you would if you
want to save more you would save it
towards the house but i'm saying i would
not invest it in a retirement account
a roth ira a 401k that's a roth with a
match
in good mutual funds all of that and
so hang on i'm going to send you a copy
of the book the total money makeover
to show you exactly how to do that
it's the step-by-step plan that we
recommend and
uh it's a number one bestseller for many
many years in a row
hang on we'll help you with that this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money dr john
deloney is here ramsey personality
to answer your questions about your life
and i'll help you with your money and
we'll both interfere with each other
it's what we do
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five
two two five mike's in sarasota florida
hey mike how are you
hey gentlemen how are you better than i
deserve sir how can we help
hey first off dave i just wanted to say
thank you very much just
over the last seven years or so you've
given me so much motivation just to
kind of you know handle our personal
finances and change our family that
it took about four years of convincing
but i was able to to convince my high
school that i work at the uh start of a
personal finance class and we just
finished up our first semester
and i've never had more fun as a teacher
teaching the subject and i and we're
helping a lot of kids along the way so i
just wanted to say thank you before i
get into the question
well thank you sir thank you for doing
that that's amazing good for you
yeah we appreciate you we appreciate you
man proud of you
yeah thank you so the the question i
have is actually in regards to my mom
uh in february and my dad passed away
when i was 18
and so i've kind of you know been
looking over her finances since i've
kind of got a little bit of an
understanding of things since then
she got about a hundred and eighty
thousand dollars
um sitting in an annuity that is kind of
a concerning product because
just to give you an idea since 2015 it's
only got about a two percent
rate of return um and i've been working
with the smart investor pro
to kind of figure out a better plan but
she's got about
60 000 left on the mortgage and we're
kind of just trying to figure out if
it's a wise decision
to pay off the mortgage she's taking out
a monthly withdrawal of about a thousand
dollars
from that 180 and obviously if that
continues on we're kind of worried that
it's going to
kind of diminish at some point in time
she's fully disabled and not
working um and so she relies on this
income
that that she gets from the annuity that
she had for my dad's life insurance
and then of course her social security
on top of that and so was kind of trying
to think and see if it's a smart
decision to
take that chunk of 60 000 out of the
annuity
well we've got to get the annuity
working harder if it were making 10
percent
that would be 18 000 a year which would
be 1500 a month
and it wouldn't be self-destructing
anymore pulling a thousand a month off
okay so yeah you got to get this money
you got to get this money moved into
something that's not two percent
you're getting killed right you're the
thing is it's it's disintegrating you're
destroying
it the goose is laying the good golden
eggs and so if that's part of the
equation
then how much is the house payment
uh it's about 1200 so i mean most of you
when you pay off the house you wouldn't
need a thousand dollars a month
correct yeah let's do both
okay let's get the income up on let's
get the annuity invested better
because now it's only 120 000
okay and let's get it invested better
and then let's not touch it
because you don't have a house payment
anymore does any of that
change by any stretch if she she's paid
a pretty exorbitant fee
when she first invested in this annuity
for a living rider
so if it does go down to zero she still
gets
roughly about a thousand dollars until
she dies
does that change the perception of it at
all no
it's because it sucks it's got a
horrible right of return
yeah it's been terrible yeah and that
that's the problem so you've got to get
it i mean smart investor pro may roll
you
into a variable annuity which is mutual
funds inside of an annuity that'll pay a
lot better than she's getting paid
but this particular product that she's
in is horrible
and so she's got to get it out you got
to get it invested better but
but the bottom line is even if it's not
it's a one-two punch even if it's not
invested better if she doesn't need the
thousand anymore because she doesn't
have a 1200
house payment anymore then
we can leave alone whatever it is that
you do with it right
sure so let's pay off the house for sure
but then the second part of it is let's
get this money invested
a little bit better and that'll help you
hey thanks for the call
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five hannah is in montgomery
alabama hi hannah welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hey mr ramsay thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
um i'm a social worker in the living
area at a non-profit
and i make about 30 000 a year um i'll
be debt free
in february and plan on having my
emergency fund by the
beginning of august fully funded and
then after that i plan on moving out of
my parents home
good for you and so my my struggle is
um at that august point is when i start
investing 15
and i don't know how to save above that
that's kind of my question
with budget balancing rent and other
extensions that come with that that i
haven't had to pay
yet with this 30 000 income and
i can't really get a second job just
because i'm on call most of the time
um so my hours would be you know
uncertain so
um just trying to get your thoughts on
that
well you could do a second job you
couldn't do the typical second job i
mean your second job could be something
that you do from home
uh on your own time a small business
idea that you could set the
computer aside and go if you got a call
uh
so we can we can you do need to do
something to increase your income on the
short term
and on the long term we've got to work
on your career yeah what type of
social worker are you i'm in
in foster care so if i do go back to get
my master's my job actually will pay for
it
um and so it's a one-year program so i
think it would be worth it but i just
um i'm not i'm not i think i don't think
i'm ready yeah i'm just i'm planning on
starting that
maybe january 2020. i'm in i'm in i
think that's a great plan
but and then develop a career path that
that uh
triples your income yeah you just
listening to how you have planned out
your
exit from your parents the way you're
executing it the way
you have a mind that is worth more than
thirty thousand dollars
here we go you have a work ethic worth
more than thirty thousand dollars and so
i think
man if you want to trade a season a one
year of of
less than you are worth because you are
getting a significant return which is a
graduate degree in a social work that's
gold
that is that's a great gift then um
that's not a bad trick
at 30 years old i don't want you sitting
there making 30. absolutely not
and i don't even want you making 45 or
55. no not with a graduate degree in
social work yeah and um
and a lot of people do yep and with that
degree field that's right
they uh they take the state job and it
doesn't pay anything that's right
and they will take every shred of your
soul
in that work because that's hard gut
wrenching emotional work
challenging yeah so the answer your
question is yes let's do some things to
get your income
up your plan to leave in august is great
your plan for the masters
in january is even better i love every
bit of it and is it okay to take a year
if you don't if you don't invest your 15
and instead you pile up a little extra
cash right now because things are close
that's okay uh you'll get around to
starting your 15
into your investments pretty soon you're
still young you've got plenty of time
the great news is you're thinking about
this which puts you way ahead of most
people because most people don't even
think this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you know health care has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had
chm chm saved our life same time
financial lives
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance
but it is a budget-friendly option and
the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
learn more today and check us out at
chministries.org
that's chministries.org
thank you for joining us america ramsey
personality dr john deloney is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five
rebecca's in orlando florida
hi rebecca welcome to the dave ramsey
show hi
dave thanks so much for taking my call
i'm very principal sure how can we help
um i have the florida prepaid program
for both of my children
um and my son doesn't think he's going
to go to college
it's not the 529 i
have a large irs debt i'm trying to
eradicate and um i was thinking
of taking the money from the florida
prepaid plan
to put it towards the irs debt
and then when my daughter's ready for
college i could just cash flow her
how much is in the prepaid plan 23 000
and how much is the irs debt 55.
what is the irs debt from it's from
three years um i'm embarrassed to say my
daughter was sick
and i was in the middle of a divorce and
um
i i was just trying to keep food on the
table and i hadn't filed for a few
okay so it's just back taxes just back
taxes
you unfiled at all and you must i ha i
have since filed
i mean you must be 10.99 or
self-employed
uh self-employed yes yeah okay so what
do you make
uh well this year with the pandemic i'll
probably make about 55.
maybe 60. that's why i got the irs on a
payment plan
uh no i actually applied for a um
an offer in compromise but i haven't
heard from them yet it's
okay um you have to you have to be able
to show pauper status
absolutely no income and no assets to
get an oic through
that's one of the great mythologies how
much did you pay for this oic
application
i put it down six thousand dollars oh
man yeah
um okay don't give me more money um
yeah that that's a there's just very
i've been doing this 30 years i've seen
two of those go through two
and uh and in both cases we were working
with a
tax attorney and you prove that they
have no assets at all
and no income and really no potential of
income
and so they really believe that you're
virtually financially dead
and you're not you make 55 000 a year so
they're going to put you on a
900 year payment plan all right um
i don't cash out kids uh college funds
for debts
but the kgb around your neck the irs
after you is not going away
so yeah i'm doing this
um all right but be forewarned that what
goes with it
the tears that you had a minute ago uh
with the shame of not having filed
because of all the stress and the
horrible things you were going through
um you're probably going to have more of
that
feeling because you just use your kids
college fund
to clean up the mess are part of the
mess
and so that's why i almost never tell
someone to use a college fund
uh even though it might make
mathematical sense is because you feel
like a dog using your kids
money that you set aside for them and i
i just want to warn you ahead of time
you're going to have that feeling
but it is still the logical thing to do
it's the right thing to do here
it is the best thing for your kids for
their mom to get straightened up
and get this get this debt out of her
life because the irs has tremendously
expensive penalties
interest and they have almost unlimited
power to
screw up your life you want to get them
out of your life
believe me it's i i it's the only kind
of debt that
terrifies me for for our clients it
terrifies me
because i've seen what the kgb does to
people
and when they decide they want to get
rough and so i just don't want you on
that
thing and i want you to get with uh one
of our tax elps
and get an installment plan working as
soon as you hear that the oic
went sideways and certainly don't see
do you list it on the oic that this
college money exists right
no because there's technically no cash
value and i didn't even think about it
until after i submitted it
oh there's technically cash value when
you cash it out you're getting cash
yeah i guess i didn't yeah i i you know
yeah if they saw that on the application
they would have grabbed it they would
have said no you're not you're going to
give us that money
so if i'm wrong i'll be happy for you
and the oic comes through and they say
you know we'll settle this 55 000 debt
for 23
000 cash it out and do it but then
you've got to really get in gear
and you got to start working with your
son and your daughter on how they're
going to get their education paid for
they're going to get really good at
taking the act test they're going to get
really good at working their butts off
while they're in school
you know pick an affordable school not
an expensive
famous school uh in-state maybe a
two-year program to get
some of the basics out of the way really
cheap all of those kinds of things
yeah that's exactly right and i'm gonna
recommend you be
real vulnerable sit down at the kitchen
table and walk your kids
um through what's happened what we're
gonna do about it
without blaming dad we're not gonna
blame anybody you're gonna take
ownership for this this is a level of
vulnerability that they're gonna feel
this tension on you and what kids do
dave is they absorb that tension and
blame themselves
especially young kids and especially
teenagers so this is a great moment for
an adult to model
hey guys here's what i did to put food
on the table wasn't right here's what
i'm doing to clean it up
here's what we're all going to do
together we're all going to start
budgeting we're all going to lean into
this stuff and is it going to be
uncomfortable oh my gosh
there's going to be some value to your
kids seeing the tears and seeing the
plan
and watching you live out of this thing
and there is a way to make meaning on
the back end of this thing
but those tears will have value it is
not a
conversation that um you portray the end
of the world
no it's a conversation that goes uh i
screwed up and here's what i'm doing and
yeah and there's a redemption there's
we're gonna make meaning of this and
things are gonna change around here and
we're all gonna do this at the table
together
yeah the good news is things are gonna
change the bad news is things are gonna
change that's right
and so the vulnerability is going to be
hard the tiers are going to be real and
the
the walking out of this is going to be
tough you still got to come with 25 000
other dollars right yeah to pay this
thing off
pandemic or otherwise you got to get
your income up and you got to get this
thing knocked out
fast yep as fast as you possibly can
hang on i'm going to send you a copy of
uh anthony o'neil's book debt-free
degree
and that'll help the kiddos start to
think that way and you start to think
that way because you're going to be cash
flowing this
a b they are too gonna be playing along
that's right
um uh see we got twenty five thousand
dollars more to clean up
with the irs if i'm wrong
and i wish i was but i'm not
hang on zach will pick up and take care
of you open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money
uh christina says since student loans
are interest free right now should i
stop paying the minimum
on all nine of my loans and focus all my
money at my lowest loan in an effort
to snowball
well uh christine student loans are
student loans and
whether they're interest-free or not
we're going to treat them the same we're
going to list that's smallest to largest
we're going to pay minimum payments on
everything but the smallest debt
regardless of what it is
and we're going to attack it with a
vengeance and when it's gone we're going
to get the next one down when it's gone
we're going to get the next one down
that is the fastest way to get out of
debt and we can add to that i would not
wait on washington to fix your problems
there's a lot of promises in the air
that biden is going to forgive all your
student loans
he might he has control of both
congresses it's
it's uh logistically legally possible
for him to get that through
but it'll be a while and while you wait
around on one foot
and then on the other for the blessings
to flow from dc
you will learn the lesson that blessings
don't come from dc
they come from grit and hard work and
ownership
yeah if you think 1400 changed your life
you didn't have a life man and you never
will if you think that that's gonna do
it
please don't sit around wait on these
guys to make your life good
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high
quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices and they make it
simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit go to
blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
michael and tasha are with us hey guys
how are you hey dave good how are you
welcome welcome where do you guys live
from indianapolis indiana well welcome
in nash welcome to nashville thanks for
joining us in person thank you very cool
congratulations how much debt have you
guys paid off
it's about a hundred and eight thousand
five hundred dollars in about 36 months
way to go and your range of income
during that time for context of the
story right before we were 105 000 to
zero for a couple months and when we
started
we ended up back at 125. cool what do
y'all do for a living
i'm a truck driver i'm in health care
okay
cool so uh what kind of debt was this
all of it everything you were normal
we didn't finance a dog or a cat but we
financed everything else
so cars student loans credit cards yes
irs
no no no irs yeah everything else though
okay
yes good wow wow fun how long you guys
been married
going on 13 years this year okay so
three years ago the story began
and it sounds like it's a wild ride what
happened
well we first heard about you in 2013
and we got very intentional for about
six months
uh we ended up moving with our job and
then just went
right back to what we were doing the old
way the normal way until
2017. in 2017 we decided to make career
transition
and that's where the zero dollar income
comes for a couple months
uh and then that was kind of the point
we
hit that said we've got to come back to
something and we actually were living in
our rv at the time
and i was digging through some paperwork
to find some things
and found your book total money makeover
and we kind of had a talk that night
when she came home and
decided we've we've got to submit his
time
and uh so we cut the credit cards up
and hit the plan wow
well way to go you guys thanks
congratulations there's nothing like
sitting in an rv
thumbing through paperwork with no jobs
going this prize and
we should probably something else
absolutely yeah and we couldn't take
that much with us in the rv so it was
crazy that out of the things
that book was with us the whole time so
we knew
what we should be doing we just didn't
do it wow yeah and it comes out kind of
jumps out at you and yells at you yeah
oh my gosh so you sat down that night
so things have got to change put it put
together the budget get the jobs get
going and game on
yep absolutely we decided uh we were
actually in ford at the time we decided
we'd put in for some jobs
in florida and back home in indianapolis
and go with what came first which was
indianapolis that's how you end up back
there
absolutely that's home originally yes
yes right cool so we both ended up with
jobs back there and that's where we went
good wow and you're killing it i mean
you're doing good 125 that's a great
income
thank you yeah what was this what was
the state of your marriage
take me back to that rv things are great
y'all on the same page
yeah i think so i think the whole time
pretty much
we were on the same page the normal i
mean we had the normal
you know couple disagreements things
like that
um so fast forward three years y'all
crushed this plan you've got new jobs
you've got new
dignity underneath you how's your
marriage now it's better
yeah even better it's just calm yeah all
the time
[Laughter]
you know when you think about at that
point you think about the fights the
disagreements which i think everybody
has but
at that point it was everything led back
to money
uh you know even the conversation about
where we can eat dinner tonight
and how we're gonna pay for it and today
it's okay where are we going to eat
dinner tonight
and there's no second guess we just go
eat dinner yeah let's do it
yeah so no money question just a dinner
it's what kind of food do we want
yeah i like it well done you guys
so what is the key to getting out at 109
036 months what's the big thing you
realize that you got to do
you have to say no uh we didn't go out
we didn't take vacations we didn't do
brunch
we did nothing everyone around us for
probably the first year kept inviting us
and then realized there was no
point so everyone left us alone
and we took turns talking each other off
of the ledge
so that was good yeah that's real strong
that's a big deal
well done how's it feel now great yeah
feels absolutely great three years of
sacrifice was it worth it
yeah it was well worth it how did you
drag your little one along
oh he's he's been he helped lead a lot
really like
yeah he was cutting the links off of our
we had a chain hanging up
so he was the link cutter um he would
overhear our conversations and he would
chime in and say i don't know if that's
what dave would tell you to do
so he's got this wired into him now he
does for sure
so you've changed your family tree for
real yes we um we have one other son
also but he's 20 and he's at work so he
could not
make the trip so he was with this whole
time as well wow
good for you guys that's fun
congratulations
so outside the two of you who and your
son who are your biggest cheerleaders
um our family uh friends i work with an
awesome group of women
as soon as we worked or came back to
indiana
um i mean they locked in and they were
cheering us on
big times that's cool that was awesome
yeah
very cool way to go you guys i'm so
proud of y'all it's so cool
yes amen man well done so what's your
son's name and age let's bring him into
the debt free scream
this is chase he'll be 11 this weekend
all right happy birthday chase
well done good stuff well we've got a
copy of chris hogan's book for you
everyday millionaires that for sure is
the next chapter in your story
you guys have done so well so proud of
you congratulations
good stuff michael and tasha and chase
indianapolis indiana 109
000 paid off in 36 months making 105-0
to now
125. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is how it's done
well done you guys very very very well
done
folks let's get real for just a second
some of you are getting close to your
baby step
four and you're freaking out because you
know you need to save 15
of your income for retirement but you do
not know how to start
investing it's scary
it's okay to have a ton of questions
it's okay to be scared about something
you've never done before
starting to invest is tricky the trick
is to work with an
investing professional like a
smartvestor pro that has the heart of a
teacher
and they can answer all those questions
in plain english
they don't sound like charlie brown's
teacher
you ever talk to somebody that just has
to has to hear themselves talk no these
guys are going to help you understand
because when it comes to investing you
need to know what you're investing in
and when you sit down and work with a
smartvestor pro who knows what the flip
they're doing they're going to help
make investing easy to understand
the heart of a teacher don't sit around
and freak out
do something about it text invest two
three three seven eight nine
that's invest to 33 789 and you can
start building wealth
today of course you can always click
smart vester pro at daveramsey.com as
well you enter your stuff it drops down
a list of the guys and gals in your area
you pick the one that you want to sit
down and
talk to and i always like to mention
this dave i just had that conversation
right before the new year with the
smartvestor pro
they put some things together for me as
a teacher in a way that
even sitting next to you for a year that
i was able to
grasp it a little bit better and they
walked me through some things
this is my money in my house with my
family and my legacy
that's where i turned and it was it was
an it was the most
clarifying conversation around it i've
ever had yeah it was good
and you know there's just power in that
yeah because if you don't know how to do
something standing next to somebody that
knows how to do it to show you
yep is the best way to learn it not
having someone do it for you that's
exactly right when you have someone do
it for you you didn't learn anything you
get you still keep
all the worry and i actually said it
like and he said
nope i need you to look at this and so
you can understand what it's gonna
what the implications of what you're
saying are ah i had to walk through it
man and that's what a teacher does
i love it nope not doing it for you i'm
gonna show you how
you are gonna do it ah this
is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day first john 5 14
and this is the confidence that we have
for him
that if we ask anything according to his
will he hears us
dale carnegie said develop success from
failures discouragement and failure
are two of the surest stepping stones
to success tim is with us in tacoma
washington hi tim welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hi dave how's it going better than i
deserve how can we help
okay so a pretty simple question but
looking for some guidance uh my wife and
i have recently gotten to a good place
where we have only the mortgage and
a famous cash loan for four thousand
dollars we have about thirty four
hundred dollars surplus in our budget
per month after
everything is paid we're looking towards
early retirement or retiring as early as
possible
so i'm curious to see if it would be
best to take that 3 400
and invest or to pay off the loan which
then we can use the house
as a rental unit and for our area it
would rent for about 2500
a month okay i'm sorry you said there
was a
two loans a home loan and a small other
loan
yes it's a four thousand dollars same as
cash um
we got a new mattress recently oh crap
okay and um and you don't have any money
in savings
i do yes i have 40 000 cash in savings i
have
30 000 in my cryptocurrency stuff which
i know tomorrow could do worth bagel but
for now it's about 30.
okay and what is the mortgage balance
it is a hundred and ninety five hundred
hundred ninety thousand five hundred we
we what's your household and we
uh we have so our growth per month our
net per month is about
seventy three hundred our expenses work
out to be
about 34 or so okay all right
well i i've been uh leading people out
of debt and into wealth for 30 years
and um and the process that we use
is um uh conservative
in in nature meaning that i don't take a
lot of risks i'm not big on risk
um and i i like to
i i don't i mean i take more risks than
some people but i some people don't take
any but
i don't put things at risk and so being
debt free
is a matter not only of being secure
but it's also a matter it puts me in a
place where i'm secure but not only that
it
gives me all that money that i was
paying to the bank to build wealth with
and to be generous with
and so that's the basis for everything
that we teach and have taught
literally millions and millions of
people okay and i tell you all that to
say
uh then in in in light of that the way
we answer questions here on this show
and you're uh new to us is to
uh say what would i do knowing what i
know if i woke up in your shoes
what's the shortest distance between
where you are
and stable and a stable
wealthy position okay now if that was me
i would write a check today and pay off
the stupid mattress and i would never
again borrow money on something like
that under any circumstances
i'd cash out the bitcoin buy close of
business today
before it's worth bagel and um
and i you know that's just that's uber
high risk
uh at best crazy at worst
um but it's uber high risk bitcoin
people don't think it is
but it is anytime you're playing a
currency of any kind
you're at the whim of the other traders
of that currency
it's the only thing that drives the
price if you're trading yen
you're trading pesos you're trading
dollars you're trading
euros you're trading whatever it is a
currency is based on
what other currency traders are willing
to lean in against it and that's all
it's worth
it doesn't have any intrinsic value uh
and
uh so same thing with gold even uh
it's it's a supply and demand curve is
what drives the price model
so it's just too high risk for me i'm
not taking that much risk it's rolling
the dice
so i'm out of there okay uh and i'm
gonna set aside some of the 40
000 for my emergency fund at three to
six months of expenses
and uh then from there i'm gonna go to
what we call baby step
four because you're out of debt and you
have your emergency fund that's one two
and three
and i'm gonna start putting 15 of your
income aside towards retirement
baby step five is to start addressing
your kids college
and baby step six is all the money above
your emergency fund
the 15 is going to come out of your
budget uh everything above your
emergency fund that you have i'm going
to start throwing towards this house to
get the house paid off as soon as
possible
of the 10 000 millionaires that we
studied in
the mo in the largest study of
millionaires ever done in north america
for chris hogan's book everyday
millionaires
we found two major components of their
wealth a paid for home
and a stacked retirement plan if you
have a net worth of five million dollars
to one million dollars to five million
dollars
most of the time roughly one-third is in
your paid for home
and roughly two-thirds is in your 401 k
those are actual researched
data points of real millionaires this is
not theory
and so if you want to go out at a
different angle you're not going at it
the way
that it actually happens that
millionaires did it right
and that's it's important to say you
know best practices
we're going to find the ways that the
most people do the successful thing
and we're going to emulate that and it's
easy to a be smart
and to have a what you think is a good
plan and you flip over a napkin and do
the math this at this percent and this
this percent we can keep this and
you can make that work out in your head
but when you ask the people who actually
do it
yeah they say man i don't owe anybody
anything
and i have uh money that i've invested
steadily over they weren't trying to get
rich quick
over time they weren't they weren't
going oh bitcoin's going to double in 90
days and so i'm gonna i'm gonna get rich
quick
and as a mental health guy what i can
tell you is when i
if i'm relying on everyone else to make
wise good decisions over the next
however long dave everybody's gone mad
so i'm not doing that i'm not doing that
man
well there's that all right deborah's
with us in new york hi deborah welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
okay um i have an issue with a
security system home security system in
my home
and i wanted to get your advice on how
can i get out of the contract
i was told that i qualified to
get out of the contract but every time i
speak to someone
i'm getting a run around
that the business that you're do the
space that you're dealing with is a
fairly dirty space there are some
good players in the home security
business and there's a whole bunch of
stinkers
sound like you got a stinker now did you
finance the actual
equipment as well into the deal yeah
so that's going to be your problem
getting out of the contract
because you actually signed a finance
contract on
the actual equipment and the monitoring
is just part of the picture
yeah but they have a um a six-month
guarantee money back and it hasn't been
six months yet but they said if you're
totally not satisfied
you know you will give your money back
in
then call them every day and if that
doesn't work start calling them three
times a day
and record the calls make sure you've
got information on your side
yeah in other words just bug the the
holy crap out of them
okay that's really all you got because
you're just trying to get people that
don't want to honor their
money-back guarantee to honor it and
you're going to be talking to somebody
on the phone who probably wants to talk
to your boss someone talk to your boss i
want to talk to your boss
i need to talk to your supervisor i need
to talk to your supervisor you can't
make the decision today
i need to get this wrapped up i've
talked to you people 63 thousand times
and i'm gonna call four times tomorrow
so i need to talk to your supervisor i
know you can't make the decision darling
please put your supervisor on
and keep a spreadsheet send emails too
so all those are time stamps
and let everybody know this is the 34th
time this is the 39th time this is 107th
time i've called
last time i talked to bob the time
before that i talked to george and then
willie are any of them still there
will equip man they all quit because
they have to take her calls from people
like her all day long
in that in that scenario so that's the
only thing i know to do uh you can hire
an attorney if you want
might cost you more than the whole
package and uh but
uh just make a hobby out of them just
mess with them
and um you know it it's uh
the squeaky wheel does get oiled i mean
you just bother the crud out of them
eventually they will they will relent
and all you're asking them to do is
uphold the contract that they agree to
right yeah just keep your word that's
all we're asking
just keep your word hard to get people
to do that though
in today's world that's for sure
all right that puts us out of the dave
ramsey showing the books thank you john
thank you man dr john deloney james
childs and zach bennett in the booth
filling in for
kelly today i am dave ramsey your host
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
[Music]
you